let's talk to a former secretary of
state for international development rory
stewart and thank you
for being with us
well what do you make of the events of
the past 24 hours everything has just
moved with alarming
speed it's absolutely extraordinary
um
from the point of view of people in
kabul terrifying
kabul was of course the most modern
part of afghanistan it was a place where
women were most active with a very
educated population and as you will
remember yourself from visits to
afghanistan
uh almost the exact opposite of the kind
of ideology the taliban is bringing so
it was a place where many refugees had
fled to get away from the taliban
they've increasingly found themselves
trapped and now taliban fighters are
entering the city and it's a terrifying
terrifying time for afghans
and what are you doing that's an image
on your screen if there's an image on
your screen of kabul itself you can see
all the shops are closed
and you can see people who look and say
they're associated with the taliban
walking down the streets and any women
out now are in burkas that's not
something you'd normally see
in fact that's the very center of the
town that's looking right at the area
where i used to work and live
normally you would have seen women there
with uncovered heads everybody has put
on traditional shower comes people are
trying to adjust now immediately to the
taliban taking over the city and do you
think adjusting to the taliban means
accepting that women's rights will be
wiped out
yes i mean the taliban are talking a
moderate game at the moment but remember
fundamentally at its core the taliban is
an extremely
disturbing organization it's used
child's
suicide bombers it provided haven to
osama bin laden
many journalists have met taliban
commanders recently who have said quite
openly that they don't believe women
should go to school
and those images that you're showing
there on the screen are absolutely
chilling i feel like i've been taken
back 20 years to the couple that i saw
just at the end of the taliban period
and as you say um the last time 96 to
2001
we did see terrorist groups get a
foothold we did see the opium and the
heroin trade grow and refugees pouring
out could it could it be different this
time the taliban are claiming it will be
different
it's going to be i'm afraid very very
dangerous remember this is a very
fragile organization the taliban they
don't actually have that many people
they've taken power largely because the
u.s and britain suddenly took its air
support away from the afghan army
totally collapsed the morale of the
afghan army so they've taken much of the
country without fighting there aren't
very many of them their hold on power is
going to be quite fragile and the danger
there
is that they will take brutal reprisals
to try to keep that hold on power
so many afghans are worried about being
imprisoned about being killed some parts
of the country afghans are already being
executed
so yes we'll hope for the best but i'm
afraid this is terrifying
and parliament is to be recalled here
what are your thoughts about the
responsibilities of the british
government now in afghanistan what
should they be doing
well this has now become a development
in humanitarian crisis it's completely
heartbreaking but we now have to work
out how on earth we can support
tens of millions of afghans in desperate
condition
the government has entirely collapsed
there will be no healthcare taking place
doctors will have gone schools won't be
open
we will end up with trying to get food
through to people so the british
government's going to have to provide
hundreds of millions if not billions of
pounds worth of
development assistance with other
nations both for refugees and people
trapped inside afghanistan and we're
going to have to think about how we help
many many afghans get out of the country
i mean if you're an educated afghan
woman this is a terrifying moment
so to you know how far do you think the
british should go on that in helping
people who want to get out get out you
think we have a responsibility beyond
you know people who have had contact
with british forces and who have
supported british forces
absolutely because remember the british
forces were just a tiny part of our
presence in that country
there were as many foreign civilians as
there were soldiers
that's people working for charities for
ngos teachers etc many of these people
will of course be targets the taliban
millions of afghans worked alongside
foreigners in different endeavors to try
to rebuild the country together and took
huge risk doing so
huge risk in very simple ways i'm
thinking of an afghan that i was
thinking about this morning who set up a
very successful high school for girls
now he's not an interpreter for the
military forces but he's exactly the
kind of person who's going to get killed
i'm going to be killed because we
created this mess
essentially our very small true presence
was like the keystone arch holding the
whole building together
and when we removed it
the whole edifice has come collapsing
down we have to take responsibility for
that and just as america did
after vietnam where they took ultimately
two and a half million three million
refugees with other european nations out
of that country
we're going to have to think about
similar measures
and anthony blinken saying today that uh
you know they inherited a deadline and
couldn't change that do you do you
accept that
no no this is absolutely heartbreaking
stuff and i you know anthony blinken is
a very smart man but it's
it's it's ridiculous
they didn't need to do this and of
course they didn't intend any of this to
happen if you can see the statements
made by secretary blinken and by
president biden even in the last few
weeks
they were talking about it being orderly
and we've just got messages now i've got
friends trying to get to the airport u.s
civilians who've just got a message from
the u.s embassy saying that there's
firing happening now at the us airport
and that they are to stay safely in
place well what on earth that means when
as you showing on your screen
taliban pickup trucks are now driving
through the streets of kabul i mean this
is a catastrophe and no the u.s of
course could have remained because its
air power and its technology was
sufficient to prevent the taliban taking
a single town with very small presence
since 2016 when combat operations ended
they've effectively contained the
taliban as a rural presence and allowed
the afghan government to continue and
civilians get on with their lives
just finally rory you just to recap you
are saying are you that we have a moral
duty to resettle
afghans who want to come here where
where would you draw the line what are
you what is your thinking about
you know how we do that
well practically we have to make this an
international effort so i would expect
britain to lead
with other nations remember there were
at any time over 40 different nato
nations on the ground
so we should be working with france
germany scandinavia with the united
states with canada with australia and
others
as in fact happened after the vietnam
war
to work out how we can provide safe
passage and asylum for afghans that want
to leave but but be in no doubt we're
talking about many many millions of
people
and this is an entirely
horrifying and unnecessary tragedy but
it's a tragedy which we bear the
responsibility for for the reckless
actions the last few weeks
okay rory stewart uh appreciate your
time this evening thank you very much
thank you very much